cutting-edge clinical trial made a
breakthrough in its effort to cure
sickle cell anemia the painful genetic
disease affects about 100,000 Americans
every year mostly African Americans
sickle cell anemia causes some red blood
cells to become deformed into a sickle
shape and die those cells clogged the
blood flow and can lead to infections or
strokes for last night 60 minutes dr.
Jon LaPook followed Janel Stephenson for
more than a year she had an innovative
kind of gene therapy at the National
Institutes of Health the therapy uses
HIV to treat patients but the virus is
weakened so it cannot cause AIDS
despite HIV s frightening reputation the
trial results well they're remarkable
this is Janelle before any treatment
right all across her blood you can see
these really abnormal shapes this one in
particular shaped like a sickle this is
nine months later this is what dr.
Tisdale saw not a sickle cell in sight
was there ever a moment where you saw
one of these normal-looking smears and
thought is this the right patient oh
absolutely
when you're a scientist you're skeptical
all the time so first thing you do is
look and make sure it's that patient go
grab another one make sure it's the same
and we've done all that and indeed her
blood looks normal remember Janelle used
to struggle just to walk up a flight of
stairs
you fall but a fall like this would have
landed her in the hospital oh yeah good
job you did it BAM Janelle you look
amazing
thank ya I have to say I was a little
nervous when you were thrown and you
went down on the mat there's nothing
it's nothing my body just felt strong I
was nervous - she looks amazing - John
watch his report last night with four
sickle cell anemia patients
Shereen Bazzi Kennard was born with the
disease Sid Rowse Stewart had her first
blood transfusion when she was just five
before he was 12
Jamal Fowler had already been admitted
to the hospital about 200 times and
Ernie Cabral says the pain from the
disease affects every single aspect of
his life they were joined by nurse
practitioner Jean
Simon from New York's Mount Sinai
Hospital what do you think it's a lot of
information to take in there's the big
positive outcome which we all hope for
but then there's the risk that you have
to weigh in as well she can be very
intimidating but it's a step in the
right direction Shireen when Janelle was
describing her pain and especially when
she was describing not being believed
that she was in pain you were shaking
your head like that because that's
that's happened to me a few times going
to the hospital in the stating this is
the disease I have this is the pain that
I'm in and they didn't understand and so
they thought I was there just to get
payments I actually wanted to cry during
that part because you're not believed at
all nobody could understand what was
happening for me have you guys
experienced a thing definitely and your
reactions were you know surprisingly
like not exactly what I expected
how sad I guess I was expecting a little
more like excitement because we've
talked about gene therapy and the
downside it's really profound and scary
but I think seeing how you reacted you
know I'm still as enthusiastic as ever
what were the scary parts to you I want
to say the number one thing yes we heard
the HIV rate I can tell you right now
that that HIV virus has been disabled
it's been crippled so it cannot infect
you
it cannot the part of it that allows it
to infect you is gone the reason why
it's used is that it's very good at
transferring DNA into a cell because I
could guarantee anybody focusing it's
exciting to know that we're making
breakthrough and yes there's a lot of
unknown variables as to what's gonna
happen five years from now the other
thing that you know a little bit
worrisome or scary is you know sickle
cell has become part of my identity it's
Who I am
and what I know and I think without the
sickle cell I would not have some of the
characteristics I have even if it's down
to my resilience or my determination and
it would be once you're cured trying to
find out who you really are who are you
now dealing with there
dealing with the struggles that come
along with it it's like that that's what
drivers that's what drivers to stay
strong to keep moving for me they kind
of gave me more of hope and just gave me
a chance to feel like I had a choice now
I'm very optimistic the possibility of a
cure that's enough that's an amazing
thing even though I say I may have the
fear of who I'm going to be does not
mean that if that opportunity was not
offered to me that I wouldn't take it
it's just something that I would have to
really think about think about dr. Luke
joins us now with a woman featured in
the 60 minutes report the lovely Janel
Stephenson good morning it's so good to
see you I love the peace last night John
when you said Janelle and Janelle you
smiled I swear you had 126 teeth your
smile was so big but the thing that got
me in the report yesterday you described
as bone crushing sharp pain you're in
the hospital on the floor and they don't
believe you take us to that moment what
are you thinking when they don't believe
the pain that you're in
it's what bothered you to me it's it's
absolutely mind-boggling just take away
the doctor/patient aspect of it and just
as human beings if you see a fellow
human being fall and you don't even
extend your hand to help them up mm-hmm
I I see a problem with that and then add
that you're a doctor on top of it it
doesn't make sense what seems to be a
common reaction because the other woman
said that you're not believed that she
was not believed - John yeah and the
question is where's the empathy yeah and
you kind of looked at well as you're the
other and I can tell you as a physician
this was very emotional for me because
from 1976 until about for about 10 years
I was taking care of a lot of patients
with sickle cell anemia and I felt
completely helpless it was like go ahead
and take care of this by the way I'm
handcuffing you we gave him some pain
medicines it really didn't help
and so now fade out fade in to see
Janelle get slammed down to the mat top
up and it was it was so emotional I mean
no words for that and not only is it a
painful disease we know it's
life-threatening also and at 22 years
old you said that you were at middle age
er now that you have the rest of your
life ahead of you how has that changed
your outlook and how well do you know
8.now okay and I just see so many
possibilities now it's no longer me
planning like my life it's not a
question of what's next it's what's
right now what can I do right now and
live in the present and the other date I
think I was going to work and I ran out
of gas and I was like this is the most
content like the most horrible thing
that can happen to me today is running
out of God like welcome to the
opportunity to have every day problem
and look at her energy she's not running
out of gas the NIH director Francis
Collins said that this looks like a cure
right how soon can this be scaled to
help other people well yeah it looks
like a cure and we're all supposed to be
scientists but we're a little bit
superstitious we don't want to jinx it
but it doesn't look like a cure and I
spoke to him a couple of days ago and he
said you know what scaling it up to the
net just so that millions of people can
be treated is very important and they're
actually on the path to do that I mean
it's technical but they're on a path to
do it where you don't need chemotherapy
and so that would make it you know
instead of being able to have it to go
through the hospital and you're in the
hospital for a month and you could have
infections just doing it very quickly
and then it could be scaled up for the
millions of people around the world who
are suffering so tell us a little bit of
what you went through though in the
treatment starting it started with the
frequent blood transfusions just on a
schedule and those alone had calms down
my crises phenomenally like I wasn't not
having as many episodes I was in the
hospital as frequent and as the trial
continued and they introduced chemo and
then my new cells of course I felt
terrible for maybe two weeks but after
that I just my body just felt stronger
and stronger in every day now it's funny
because I could actually feel the cells
engrafting in my body like I felt them
soaking in there
but what was it like knowing there were
no guarantees you know that your this
was still a trial knowing you could
still possibly die the way I looked at
it was I will take any chance any chance
I don't really I'm not concerned with
the negative outcomes of it because what
I was going through and living with up
until that point I couldn't do it
anymore
it's too much and you weren't alone you
were with your family how quickly how
was your father ray who's not your size
he was great
he's really happy the last thing I
wanted to say say is that we found out
last night in Janelle and I were talking
it's a little destabilizing in terms of
your identity I mean who are you the old
you in the new you and it you know when
she got home who was like she was a
Maserati right but she was going like 30
miles an hour she's afraid let's just
open this thing up and she started doing
all these activities well it's
impressive new you Jim thanks John